JOANNA SMITH: Hi everybody,
happy Halloween!
I'm Joanna Smith and I'm a
developer programs engineer
here at Google.
And today I have Gus
Class with me.
GUS CLASS: Hi, I'm Gus Class.
I'm a developer advocate
on Google+.
JOANNA SMITH: And we're both
really excited because today
we are actually going to
showcase some of our favorite
apps from the community.
And so I guess let's go ahead
and do some introductions and
see who we've got here
with us today.
ABRAHAM: I'm in tech start up,
and if you've been on the
Google group you've probably
seen some posts from
me or run into me.
So yeah, that's me.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Hi there,
I'm Allen Firstenberg.
I'm located in New York.
I've contributed to the Hangout
Comment Tracker, I've
done some work with the caption
app and a couple of
other small utility apps.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Hi there, I'm
RobotGrrl and these are my
robots, RoboBrrd, and recently
I made a Google+ Hangout
extension for them
to [INAUDIBLE].
GERWIN STURM: Hi, I'm
Gerwin from Austria.
You probably know me from
tools like [INAUDIBLE]
plus statistics or the Comment
Tracker and I'm always up to
do some fun stuff.
So I only just started
a project last
night, so you'll see.
JOANNA SMITH: Moritz,
we can't hear you.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Sorry.
I'm Moritz.
I'm Moritz Tolxdorff from
Germany, and I started playing
with the Hangouts API and my
first app was the Hangout
Lower Third, and some people
might know this app.
And I recently combined all my
apps in the Hangout Toolbox
and also included Gerwin's
Comment Tracker, which is a
great addition to the Toolbox.
GUS CLASS: It looks like
you're replacing your
background there too.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah, but
that's not a Hangout app.
Unfortunately.
JOANNA SMITH: Well,
we like it.
GUS CLASS: We like it.
JOANNA SMITH: So Gus and
I are really excited.
It seems like we've got some
really awesome people here,
and I hope that everyone
watching really enjoys
learning from them as well.
And I think we're just going
to jump into our demos,
beginning with Erin RobotGrrl.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: So the demo of
this is basically, there's
this web app slash Google+
Hangout extension with buttons
on it that list out
various fruits.
And then you touch the
button and then it
can feed the RoboBrrds.
And then you can see
the reaction here.
[INAUDIBLE].
JOANNA SMITH: Now, Erin, you
posted a link where viewers
can actually play with the
RoboBrrds themselves, right?
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Yep.
[INAUDIBLE]
tinyurl.com/robobrrdfeeder.
And then you can feed
them as well.
And it's pretty hungry,
so please feed it.
JOANNA SMITH: That's
really cool.
So what inspired this
app in particular?
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: In particular,
well, I have a
robot party each week.
And I created one before that
that worked with a robot with
tank treads on it.
And it was cool to drive her
around everywhere, but I
didn't have it for my RoboBrrds
yet, so I wanted to
make that for RoboBrrding.
Actually, the root of the
inspiration for the tank tread
robot was the Oscar robot, which
Gus created with the
Google+ Hangout stuff as well.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
So you took a similar approach
where you had a web server
running, and then that's
connected to Arduino, and then
so you actually trigger the some
sort of routine on the
Arduino through a web page.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Yep, exactly.
The way I have it set up is a
little bit different than
yours, but the same
general idea.
I have it on an EC2 instance
running like a node.js app,
which is this web app
thing that you see
on the screen there.
And then that's sending out the
data through a TCP socket,
and then I have a processing
sketch that's listening to
that socket, and then it
sends that data to
the Arduino via serial.
And then the robot listens,
and then it just does
something based off of that.
GUS CLASS: That's awesome.
JOANNA SMITH: That's so cool.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: One thing that
I was really surprised about
was that there isn't that much
lag, so it's really cool to
see its really instant
when you press
it and then it reacts.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, that's
definitely a great advantage
of using the web
sockets, right?
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Yeah.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, awesome.
JOANNA SMITH: I like also that
you just were able to
basically steal from Gus, like
the Oscar the Hangout robot.
That's really cool.
We love to see people take
ideas and run with them.
GUS CLASS: Yeah,
reuse is good.
All right, so, do you
have any questions
for us or any feedback?
Any things you learned or any
big challenges that you had
when you were working with
us, or was it pretty
straightforward?
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Well, there was
one time when I was trying
to add in Google Analytics to,
I think, the Hangout XML and
then it didn't work and I
couldn't figure out why.
And then I just had to remove
everything and try everything
again, so that was
a little weird.
I don't know why
that happened.
JOANNA SMITH: Did you file a bug
in our issue tracker when
you encountered that?
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: No, because I
wasn't sure if it was an issue
with bugs, I was thinking
it was probably mine.
JOANNA SMITH: It might have been
yours, but I think it's
always worth filing those bugs
because if nothing else I'll
at least promise to read it, and
then we'll see if we can
reproduce it on our end.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: OK.
Cool.
JOANNA SMITH: Anything else?
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Actually, the
first web app that I've
created, so eventually
I want to add in
more Hangout API stuff.
So that maybe I could get a
robot to say whoever's in the
Hangout out loud using text
to speech or something.
GUS CLASS: That could
be really awesome.
JOANNA SMITH: That
would be so fun.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Yeah.
So I'm slowly learning all
this web app stuff.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, great, yeah.
And as you're learning if you
think of questions, just send
them to be on Google+
and we'll definitely
try to help you out.
And there's always our forum.
And then any really good
questions we'll just mention
on our next Office Hours for
other people to learn too.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Cool.
JOANNA SMITH: Cool.
They really are hungry.
GUS CLASS: So up next
we'll have--
JOANNA SMITH: We'll
have Gerwin next.
GUS CLASS: We'll have Gerwin.
GERWIN STURM: Last night I got
this great idea that I want to
add a Rubik's cube to Hangout
so that people can play with
their Rubik's Cube together.
So, I only started a little bit
of hacking today, so I'm
just going to screen share
what I have so far.
It's not in the Hangout yet.
It's a cube.
See?
It's a cube, and you can
actually spin it around.
And so what I'm really proud of,
this is all just CSS and
JavaScript and HTML5, so no
Flash, no nothing, and
you can play it.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
GERWIN STURM: So you can
actually solve it already if
you know how to.
So this will run, so actually
this can already run in the
Hangout, but it doesn't make a
difference because it's not
sharing this state yet.
So what I'm planning to do is
adding a shared state so
everybody will see the same
cube, but they can still
orient the cube like
they want to.
Everybody can look on from
their own direction.
And then if somebody moves, this
will be shared with all
the others.
So what I'm not quite sure yet
is how this will work if two
people click at the same time,
which might be a problem.
So I'm not quite sure how I'm
going to solve it from a
technical side, but what I'm
thinking is that I will have
the shared state to always
represent the full cube.
And then I'm going to send out
quick messages, with the sent
message, just to say, OK, this
person rotated the top layer,
for example.
So that everybody can see the
movement, and then when the
shared state comes.
So the shared state will always
have a well-lit cube in
it, at least.
JOANNA SMITH: That's cool.
Are you going to add maybe the
ability to have multiple cubes
so that people can race each
other or something?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah,
that would work.
Maybe.
JOANNA SMITH: That's something
that I would definitely do.
I'm not competitive,
don't worry.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, there's kind
of an interesting challenge
there, where it's kind of like,
what prevents two people
from making moves at
the same time?
And so you can do a turn taking
sort of approach.
Have you thought of that?
GERWIN STURM: That's what it was
one of my thoughts to let
people have.
JOANNA SMITH: Hold on,
it just came to our
attention that we had--
[INAUDIBLE]
GUS CLASS: All right,
we're back.
Magically.
All right, so we'll start
where we left off.
Gerwin, you were showing
us your Rubik's cube.
OK, I can see it.
And so, you can move
the cube around.
GERWIN STURM: And the easiest
way to solve it is just to
refresh the page.
GUS CLASS: That's the fastest
Rubik's cube solve ever.
ABRAHAM: If only life
was more like that.
JOANNA SMITH: You can solve it
in a minute, well I can solve
it in a click.
GERWIN STURM: Actually because
this is all just HTML and CSS,
you can actually just go into
the Inspector and change the
colors like you would change
the stickers around.
So you can do all the cheating
then as well in the Hangout.
JOANNA SMITH: Good,
yeah, we want to
encourage proper cheating.
It's not real world
without that.
GERWIN STURM: And just
wait, I have--
I'm just going to show you.
So that's why.
I'm just combining
things I love.
So I love the Hangout API
and love Rubik's cubes.
GUS CLASS: There you go.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: So you were
just sitting there looking for
some inspiration and it just
sort of came to you?
GERWIN STURM: Popped
into my face.
GUS CLASS: That's awesome.
GERWIN STURM: And actually,
Allen, your work on your game,
when we started, we talked
a little bit about CSS
transforms.
That's how I got the idea, wait
maybe I'll do a Rubik's
cube just in CSS.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I was
wondering if that inspired it
in any way.
At one point I was working on
a 3D tic-tac-toe game, and
Gerwin suggested that I look
into 3D transformations to see
if I could represent the boards
using that, and I did
some work on it.
GUS CLASS: That's awesome.
I think it looks great.
I like how they're kind
of translucent, too.
GERWIN STURM: I thought it was
fun to just make it a little
bit more special somehow.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, that's
real fun.
I can't wait to play
with it once
you've got into a Hangout.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah you're going
to kill mine and Gus's
productivity so hard.
All right, so let's go ahead and
see what Moritz brought.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah, as I
said earlier, that I combined
all my tools in the
Hangout Toolbox.
I want to show you this
app real quick.
I hope it's readable
on the screen.
It might be a bit pixelated.
But this is my Hangout Toolbox,
and I basically took
all my apps I released so far
and combined them in one app,
because there was an issue that
you're not able to load
multiple apps as an extension
at the same time.
They replace each other once
you load an extension.
So, for example, if I would load
up Google Effects right
now, my Hangout Toolbox
would be gone.
And I heard from a lot of people
that they use Hangout
Lower Third and Volume Control
and Comment Tracker and
Hangouts On Air, and you weren't
able to run them
simultaneously at
the same time.
So I had to resolve this problem
on my own until Google
maybe someday releases something
new that you can run
multiple apps at
the same time.
So I had this idea to combine
all these apps in one big app.
And this is what I basically
did, so you have the Hangout
Lower Third part where
you can select all
your Lower Third stuff.
You can select your own color
in the recent version.
So that's also the point that
I'm not updating my current or
my original Lower Third app
anymore, I'm only maintaining
the Lower Third part in
the Hangout Toolbox.
If users want to have the latest
Lower Third app, they
should use the Hangout
Toolbox.
You can also select your country
flag and display that
as an icon within your
Lower Third.
You have the Volume Control,
where you can adjust the
volume for each participant
in the Hangout.
If there's some user who has a
very loud microphone or is a
bit silent, you can just
tune it up or down.
Or you can even mute them
completely, or the whole
Hangout if you get a phone
call or whatever.
It's some sort of emergency
button.
You can just click it and the
whole Hangout gets muted, and
your microphone gets muted as
well, so you can watch a video
and get on the phone
or whatever.
And then jump back
into the Hangout.
And then you have the meme face
part, where you have some
funny meme faces you can put
on your face, like this.
I'm not sure if it's
working right now.
No, it's not detecting
my face.
It's like face tracking
overlay.
Abraham is using the Google
Effects app right now with the
hats and stuff.
ABRAHAM: No.
This is how I look every day.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: This is
basically the same API method
I'm using here.
And you can also put in a URL
for your own face you want to
put in there.
And then the sound board is
also part of the Google
Effects, I just extended
it a little bit more
from some more sounds.
Or some Pacman sounds
or whatever.
And yeah, the most recent
addition is the Comment
Tracker, which Gerwin
developed.
Which is very useful, especially
in Hangouts On Air,
where you have the YouTube
comments and the comments on
Google+ and maybe
also on Twitter.
And you can combine all those
sources into one stream within
the Hangout so you don't have to
click through tabs and try
to aggregate all the
different comments
from different sources.
You have everything
in one stream.
And it also scans the re-shares
of Google+ posts so
you don't have to find
those re-shares.
The app does it for you.
And once you have all the
sources set up, you can also
share the sources with other
participants running the app,
so they can follow the
stream as well.
So if I put in, for example,
the URL from this Hangout
here, it shows me here the
Hangout, and there's also
already one comment.
And I can also click on View and
then it will display the
comment on screen so people
in the Hangout On Air can
actually read the comment.
GUS CLASS: Oh, that's cool.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: So this is
a really cool app Gerwin
developed there.
And combining that with Lower
Third and all the other stuff
is really a valuable tool
for Hangouts On Air.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, that's
really fun.
So it looks like you're kind
of using the whole
breadth of the APIs.
Are there any specific
highlights you may want to
call out here?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Well, most of
it is just the Hangout API.
Plus a bit of the Google+ API
as well, and the Common
Tracker, the YouTube API.
And Gerwin, correct me if I'm
wrong, but are there any other
API's you're using in the
Comment Tracker so far?
GERWIN STURM: The Twitter API.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Oh, yeah,
the Twitter API.
GERWIN STURM: Not the Google.
JOANNA SMITH: You were talking
about how your main motivation
was to be able to aggregate all
of the different apps that
you wanted to use into one.
Did you find that difficult to
do, or was it actually fairly
straightforward once you
had each app developed?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: It was
surprisingly easy.
I had all the single apps and
once I had the idea and
started on this [INAUDIBLE]
I just loaded in every single
JavaScript file from all my
apps, and it just worked.
I was really surprised.
I didn't have to do many
customizations or
modifications to my basic apps,
they were just included
in the overall app and
it was just working.
So it was really
easy to build.
JOANNA SMITH: That's really
encouraging hear.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, that's great.
JOANNA SMITH: So I'm going to
go ahead and mention this,
anybody who's watching who has
questions for our developers
or for Gus and I. Go ahead and
make a comment on either the
Google+ event or on the YouTube
live stream, and that
way we can address
your questions.
But I think from here on out
we're all just going to sit
around and chat about the APIs
and about developing for a
little while while we wait for
those questions to roll in.
So back to you, Moritz, and
whatever you were saying.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: One of the
things that I wanted to bring
up is that a lot of the stuff
that Moritz has done has been
really to help out people who
are doing Hangouts On Air or
people who are producing
Hangouts.
And we see a lot of people who
will often come to us and say,
hey can you do this, or I'm
encountering this problem with
the Hangout, is there
something that
you guys can do?
I got a question a month or so
back with someone saying, I'm
using Hangouts On Air to
place a phone call.
And while that feature works
really well, sometimes I'll
place a phone call and then I
need to enter an extension.
And they asked if there was a
way that they could then touch
tone in another extension.
So I cooked up a quick app that
would let you do your own
touch tones as part of it.
And that's something that I'm
looking to extend a little to
make it easier if you're
frequently calling extensions
or frequently doing this
sorts of thing.
But those are the sorts of
things that we can do, and I
think that's the power behind
the Hangout API.
JOANNA SMITH: That's a
really good point.
That's awesome.
GUS CLASS: If you can dream it,
you can build it, right?
Or if somebody wants it you
can usually solve their
problem too.
ABRAHAM: And if you can build
it, you can charge for it.
I was actually surprised by how
Gerwin could say, here is
the Rubik's Cube, and if you
can't solve it then you can
use in-app payments and pay
me a dollar and I'll
solve it for you.
And then he can retire
to the Bahamas.
GUS CLASS: That's
the profit part.
The final step.
JOANNA SMITH: Monetize
this, yeah.
GUS CLASS: Yeah,
that's awesome.
JOANNA SMITH: I want to
charge a dollar for
solving a Rubik's cube.
I should charge Gus a dollar
every time I fix his Buckyball
structures.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, that's true,
I'm always breaking them.
I think that they break
on their own.
JOANNA SMITH: No, I think it's
because you smash them.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: What,
the Buckyballs?
GUS CLASS: Buckyballs, yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: I'll build
something for Gus and he just
smashes it.
Just smashes it, every time.
GUS CLASS: Yeah you may not
know it, but Joanna is
actually an extremely talented
Buckyball crafter.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: You know,
also these bad boys here.
JOANNA SMITH: Hexiflexigon?
No, what's that?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: That a ball of
wax in the Chrome edition.
JOANNA SMITH: Nice!
GUS CLASS: Oh, wow.
JOANNA SMITH: Oh,
you're green.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: The green part
just gets chroma keyed.
JOANNA SMITH: He green
screened it.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: [INAUDIBLE]
you can also build, like,
crazy forms out of it.
ABRAHAM: You could even charge
a dollar to feed the birds.
GUS CLASS: There you
go, charge a
dollar to feed the birds.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: That might be
a little crazy [INAUDIBLE].
JOANNA SMITH: It's just like
real life at that point.
Those are some hungry birds.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: I really hope
that Google will extend
the APIs a bit more.
I mean, we can do a lot of
awesome stuff right now, but
there is room for more.
I mean, we have a
lot of ideas.
I mean, especially Gerwin, Allen
and I, and Erin as well,
and a lot of other developers.
We have ideas, and at some point
we reach a dead end with
the current API.
I mean, we are in kind of
close contact with the
developers working on the API
and give them feedback in what
our ideas look like and where
we could extend the API or
where we need some more
features from the API.
And they usually listen to our
feedback, and they do it in
the next release.
And I think especially with
Hangouts On Air, they can
include some more features.
Giving you more control.
JOANNA SMITH: This was actually
one of the questions
that we got in advance
was from Roy.
And they asked why the updates
for Google+ are so slow, and
why it takes so long for new
features to come out.
And I think what's important to
realize is that Google+ is
taking, as a product, as a
company, we're taking a very
careful approach, where we want
to make sure that when we
do things, we do them right.
And it does mean that sometimes
we move a little
slower than people would like,
but it also means that
hopefully we'll never have to do
a really big backtracking.
We'll never have to take a
step back and be like, oh
gosh, that was bad.
We're trying really hard to make
sure we do what's right
for our users as well
as our developers.
We do appreciate the patience
of our developers, but we do
admit that it is slower than
they would like as well.
GUS CLASS: And I mean, actually,
we do also try as
best we can to listen to
developers, and so Moritz,
whenever you encounter that kind
of stuff you let us know.
And I think that's pretty much
what we're saying, too, is we
do respond when developers say,
we could do so much more
if we had just another flag on
this API that would let me
turn on and off this feature.
That kind of stuff is really
useful for us to know, and it
helps us help you create
really good products.
JOANNA SMITH: Right, so talk
about it in our forums, and
post it on G+ and submit it to
the issue tracker, and we're
going to get those bugs filed
and try to get those
features out there.
Especially if it's one that's
requested often or requested
by one of our top developers.
Because you guys, you know
you're the best, but other
people out there are trying
become good and sometimes it
definitely takes a little bit
more time and a little bit
more attention.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: The birds
are going crazy.
GUS CLASS: The birds
are being fed.
JOANNA SMITH: We need Moritz's
toolbar to quiet those birds.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah but
totally, I totally agree that
the developers, or the
engineers, from Google are
really great and into the
community and really helpful
and engaging with people,
even if it's on
Google+ or in the forums.
The communication is really
great, and they really listen
and care about users'
feedback.
And I really like that.
I mean, I've never experienced
any other company doing that
in such a great way.
GUS CLASS: Well, thank you
for telling us that.
That makes us feel
really good.
And we have the awesomest
developers too, you know that.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Talking about
the issue tracker, I
found an issue and I'm still
waiting for a response.
JOANNA SMITH: I didn't say
I'd respond, I said
I'd read them all.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: It's actually
a part of the Hangout
API where I think there's
something wrong.
I think it's not even in the
API, I think it's in the talk
plug-in or something, because
when I'm using the Hangout
Mute function from my Toolbox,
it's muting all participants,
but after a while I can
hear them again.
Even if their audible status
is still set to false, so I
shouldn't be able to hear them
at all, but I can hear them.
So there's something
weird going on and
I don't know what.
JOANNA SMITH: I did
read that one.
I spent about 20 minutes trying
to reproduce it and had
some trouble waiting for
it to kick back in.
And then I gave up
for the day.
Part of my work schedule, I
actually dedicate x number of
hours every week to just sitting
in the issue tracker
and working through that and
filing the bugs accordingly.
So it's definitely something
that they're aware of.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: I think you
can reproduce it faster when
you start clicking
participants in the film strip.
JOANNA SMITH: To like
focus on them?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: OK, that's
good to know.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Then it
happens more often, the audio
switches on again for
specific people.
JOANNA SMITH: That actually
makes it--
OK, yeah, I'll definitely try
that later, today probably.
GUS CLASS: The birds
are being fed.
So for other participants in the
Hangout, can you guys turn
on the app and feed the birds?
Have you guys been feeding
the birds all day?
ABRAHAM: I fed them a
little bit earlier.
JOANNA SMITH: There's
the tiny URL.
GUS CLASS: Oh that's right.
JOANNA SMITH: See if that
can feed these birds.
GUS CLASS: So then everybody
can feed the birds.
JOANNA SMITH: Ah, I just
got a strawberry.
GUS CLASS: Oh, there it is.
JOANNA SMITH: I like the
different hats, Erin.
That's cool.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Yeah, well, this
one whenever you change
his hat, [INAUDIBLE].
And it actually [INAUDIBLE],
so that's pretty cool.
Would you like to see the
inside [INAUDIBLE]
part of it?
JOANNA SMITH: Show the
inside, definitely.
GUS CLASS: And again, and as
always we'll be watching the
event and YouTube
for comments.
JOANNA SMITH: So far the
only comment seems to
be saying good job.
So somebody likes one of you.
GUS CLASS: Somebody likes us.
JOANNA SMITH: I don't know which
one of you but we'll
assume all of you.
GUS CLASS: Looks like
an Arduino in there?
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Yeah, this
one's actually one of my
custom made Arduinos, so, I
made an Arduino derivative
that looks like this.
GUS CLASS: OK cool, yeah.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: There we go.
So it has a pretty cool
silk screen on it just
like a basic Arduino.
JOANNA SMITH: Did you
laser etch that?
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: No.
It's just standard PCV material
with a [INAUDIBLE]
silk screen on it.
And then inside you can
sort of see the beak
mechanism in there.
And the beak mechanism is what
translates the rotational
movement from the servo into
linear movements so that it
can open and close its
beak over here.
So let's see.
If you feed it, something
happens.
[INAUDIBLE].
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah, I
can see it, yeah.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: It is very
impressive that it works kind
of instant.
I mean, I'm sharing the app
window from the Hangout, and
now that I'm clicking, the bird
is actually moving, so
there's actually no delay.
GUS CLASS: No delay.
Yeah, you can hear it.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah, great work with the
web sockets there.
ERIN ROBOTGRRL: Thank you.
GUS CLASS: We'll have to
add it to Oscar now.
JOANNA SMITH: Got
to step it up.
GUS CLASS: Got to step
it up, yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: Got some
competition on.
OK, well, it doesn't seem like
we have very many questions
coming in today.
But, as always, if you think of
some later and you want to
go ahead and ask them, just
comment on the YouTube event
or the Google+ event and I'll
come back and look at it.
Or Gus will, or another
member of our team.
As far as announcements go,
this week we don't have
anything to announce.
But we do hope that everybody
has a Happy Halloween.
And we would like to thank our
awesome friends for being
willing to spend their Tuesday
afternoons, or evenings, or
maybe Wednesday morning, I can't
quite tell by the time
difference, with us.
And we really appreciate that.
So thank you, you guys.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, thank you
everyone for coming in, and
thanks everyone for watching.
Have a good Halloween.